- Hi, I'm Mark Epstein.
I'm a School Programs Educator
here at the Museum of Modern Art
and today, I'm gonna talk about
Richard Serra's piece, To Lift.
When I bring students to this object,
what I like to do first is have them
walk around the piece
and if you walk around the piece,
you really can start to notice
these amazing indentations in the surface
and we don't know exactly what
the history of this piece is,
but it looks like things have happened.
There's little nicks in
the surface over there.
What I have students do,
after they walk around,
is they do a sketch of the
piece for a couple of minutes
and then they also think about,
if they could title the piece,
what the title would be.
And we talk about the titles
that they have come up with
and they're, they run the gamut from
sort of really dark, somebody
called it Satan's cave one day
to somebody called it
Edible Scarf the other day.
And we talk about the titles and we try
and group the titles and
see if there's anything
in common about them.
And then what we do is we,
just do some observation.
So, we talk about what
the piece is made out of.
We try and guess by looking
at the surface down there
and we come to the fact that it's flexible
and then I go into some information about
what Richard Serra was
actually trying to do,
about the process that he
used to make the piece.
I think students are surprised to see
an object that's made out of a really
inexpensive, every day material.
Kids say often that it
reminds them of the,
the material you put under carpeting
so the carpeting stays in place.
And I think that they
really relate to this idea
that Richard Serra took
this every day material
and then he's in his studio
and he's just sort of
seeing what he can do to it.
And I think there's a playfulness
that kids really relate to
that they don't expect to necessarily find
in modern and contemporary art.
I'm really drawn to this
object as an artist because
you can really see the gesture in it.
You can imagine Richard
Serra in the studio
lifting the piece.
And I'm also really intrigued by the idea
that the gesture is repeated
by an installer or a team of installers
every time the piece is installed.
For students, makes them
think about the possibilities
of art work and think that art work is
not just created with brushes and paint.
It's not just created with,
ya know, welding and steel.
It can be created from
anything around them
and hopefully it gives
them a different view
when they're walking down the street,
looking at things in piles that like,
hey this is a possibility
for an art material
and I love that.